a great stick-to-your-ribs - here's my
favorite beef an ale with mustard
dumplings
[Music]
and helping in the kitchen is my
youngest Tilly
[Music]
Tilly first things first I'd like you to
season the students take a nice spoon of
flour yeah what's our going to do dad
the flour helps to brown the beef as
seasoned flour will also help to add
flavor and thicken the stew look at the
size of the chunks of the beef and I cut
my carrots literally it'd be similar
similar sizes fire does that mean
they'll cook equally that's right now
these are no elements and put them in
hold as well
everything has to stay the same
otherwise it could burn always seem burn
garlic before it's different
hamid tilter shame i'm gonna mix in that
why is that time time and well they
and faders could go tablespoon of oil in
the beef goes in first okay
[Music]
it's our people color in with the
carrots timing could go garlic pearl
onions in good you got a really good mix
up
[Music]
Jews are very easy to May providing at
the beginning you give it a little bit
of love now the song booth the ground
that is beer and let's go the glaze the
pan having beer or stout helps to
tenderize the beef and give it a hearty
delicious flavor and that's the only way
I want you to taste beer Ennis - yeah
I'm having a cup of tea spoons
that's rather pureed please insight
three please
there's one final thing in there cover
this cheering steak with a beef stock
give that a little mix with Danny please
[Music]
Wow that's really nice it's not even
cooked yet do you keep all these
vegetables in when you stir em servant
oh yes it's the garlic game to be burnt
that excuse me right we always put the
lid with a little bit so it can be
that's right I do not make the stew or
watery into the oven at 150 please tails
for about two half hours and now you can
focus on your homework you smell the
beef no it's even gone down a bit
I want you to just I was hoping you'd
ask does have a little taste
how's that taste now not allowed anymore
dumping time flour in please I'm using
self-raising flour for a fluffy result
but if you like your dumplings hard use
plain flour next the dumpling essential
to it that makes the dumplings nice and
moist
thank you
followed by a generous dollop of grain
mustard two fingers start rolling the
fingers round and I'll touch a warm
water hit your fingers are now a nice
little whisk fingers are getting tired
right now put your hand in there and I
should be all that dough together
actually the best way to get that nice
and clean
Springs of flour on your hands but them
together all that will come off is that
now but it's wonderful dumpling mixture
task which is that little flour on your
hands
okay roll these lengthwise and then I
want you to following on that and you
know I figure smell that mustard in
there beating yes please
silly gently let's go in at 12 top one
or top 12 in the center put that back
into the oven for 20 minutes to cook the
dumpling sense now
look they've sort of doubled in size
definitely
a final sprinkling of chopped parsley
and ice - is ready for the table I might
have to have a quick taste before we go
just the check I mean we'd have to be
sure we have to be very sure mmm that is
an amazing party [ __ ] killer dumplings
are you ready for some delicious beef
stew that's delicious
thank you we'll be able to heat this up
from one mandjak when they come back
easy
evening - three days later posted
[Music]